we want to take a second now to talk
about why all this matters Donald Trump
has been called a lot of things but
being called individual one may be the
most damaging that's how he's referred
to in Michael Cohen's plea agreement
there's been a lot of drama in the Trump
presidency but now a man with access to
the president's intimate secrets says
the president directed a crime that's
what makes this moment different no
matter what plane a president travels in
it's called Air Force One and with
presidential scandals critics always
tried to make the President individual
one the centerpiece of the event even if
the president has no direct involvement
Paul Manafort for example was convicted
of crimes he committed before he ever
worked for Donald Trump on the question
of Russian collusion the president's son
and son-in-law are implicated but he has
not been what makes the Michael Cohen
case different is that he is pointing
right at the president saying President
Trump was involved in a proven crime the
president can't say didn't know Cohen or
wasn't involved
he's on tape Michael Cohen may be lying
that was one of his key job requirements
but that's also what made him the swamp
captain navigating the material it was
most important for the candidate to hide
Donald Trump has boasted he alone can
fix the economy North Korea and
America's trade deficit but when it
comes to Cohen's work he must now
convince people of the opposite that he
is not individual one you take what
you've just said and juxtapose that with
what we saw the president do last night
in West Virginia before a crowd in a
rally where he didn't address this issue
the crowd didn't seem bothered by what
was happening in New York City in
Manhattan and in Virginia outside the
courthouse there with Paul man affords
as if two different worlds
the transpiring at once it's on two
tracks yeah trying to keeping them
separate though will be quite a job that
is and what about members of Congress
John understanding that there are
divisions in this country but what can
people expect from their elected
representatives
well Republican members of Congress are
the keys because they're in control and
what motivates them the most
they are risk-averse because they're
politicians in an election year what
motivates them is what the base of the
party believes the base is right behind
president Trump all right to be
continued